what do you think antigua thinks of joe
biden
there's probably a hope that after biden
won the election perhaps the antifa
violence would calm down
yeah so that didn't happen uh
we're now um many weeks until
2021 uh months after trump had won the
election in november
and there's been more than a dozen riots
that have happened
in the pacific northwest
some people were surprised they thought
oh these are dumb uh these abiding
supporters
no they're not actually if you look at
what they say look at the banners for
example one of the banners that they
carried on the
their inauguration day riot in portland
was a large one that said we don't want
biden we want revenge
and there's a large image of a question
called rifle
if that wasn't thoughtful enough
and so they don't recognize
the american government period they're
working to overthrow it they don't
recognize
any president the legitimacy of any
president
so that means opposing before the
current administration yes opposing
trump
but opposing any administration that
would replace trump anyways
because they don't see the us government
as legitimate they view it as a fascist
state that must be overthrown
so this is what i mean when i say that
people on the mainstream left who have
been
feeding and feeding and growing this
beast because they shared a mutual enemy
in the trump administration or against
republicans whatever
well now this beast is too big
to slay and we've seen the violence
after carried out they've attacked
they've assaulted
the mayor of portland the mayor portland
ten wheeler
is somebody who gave them the space to
grow
under his watch and they turn around and
have attacked him
they showed up to the homes of people on
city council
uh in portland for example who uh
voted against um defunding the police
so and the thing is they're not getting
held accountable when they're carrying
out these criminal activities
it's not just that they're doing it it's
that they're doing it
and then doing it over and over and over
because there's no consequence
so one of the projects that i'm known
for is getting the
public records of people who are
arrested at riots
and we have now a sample size and just
important of
around a thousand cases and the
overwhelming majority
by that i mean more than 90 percent how
the charges immediately dropped
by the prosecutor who is a politician
it's an elected position
who campaigned on a so-called
progressive platform
and as soon as he came into office last
summer he
literally decriminalize felony rally
chain that was one of the things that
will be automatically discharged so
um like
this is the reality
what's happening in parts of america um
it's not hyperbole when the doj
last year described some parts of the us
as an as anarchist jurisdictions because
you do have a breakdown of the rule of
law the system's not working
and these extremists are exploiting
civil rights human rights to carry out
their wanton violence
in the name of free speech and right to
protest
and unfortunately they've been given
cover you know i keep going back to the
media
because they wouldn't have been able to
do so much damage
if there wasn't this
antifa talking point that was mainstream
which claims that
um people over property that the
looting and breaking and starting pliers
and destroying buildings and distances
that's not violence because uh it's on
an inanimate
object like
this is like portland is really a
first world slum if you go to its
downtown
like they're trying to
create an environment where people don't
have trust in law enforcement on one
level and two
law enforcement just don't have the
resources to even respond
to crimes that are happening in the
cities we have a huge uptick
in most american urban
areas and put in in violence um
police officers uh across many many
departments are resigning in droves or
taking early retirement
so all the conditions that allowed
things to get so bad in 2020 they're all
still there
and trump was never a real variable that
was just a convenient excuse
that's terrifying man there's so many
points that i agree with there
specifically talking about how allowing
them to
uh embed in create these
organizational structures and also sort
of the intellectual structures
understanding how they need
to develop and then writing up you go
through basically a curriculum
in the book of how they indoctrinate and
train
new members into antifa but it's kind of
the same way that a cancer
grows you know if it's just one cell
that turns the other cells around it can
attack
but after a little bit of time if you
get too many cells they can metastasize
and actually turn into a genuine cancer
and that's a much bigger operation to
try and get rid of and
it seems to be the same i mean
a first world slum in somewhere like
portland
and wasn't it the homicide rate
increased by 200 percent
the most it's been in a number of
decades something like that
correct that's right thank you during
the height of the riots
so we've been having this unprecedented
unprecedented
unprecedented level rise in shootings
and
gun related homicides in portland and
this is
like antifa have been celebrating this
they're really happy
because the whole they want they say
they want to abolish
the american criminal justice system
abolish
police and all that but what they
essentially want to be is
to replace the police with their own
paramilitary type groups and
the cities under weak
police leadership under weak city
council and weak state leadership
have allowed them to do it and so i'm
not
even exaggerating when i say that
in last year in particular when the
riots were happening every night
parts of downtown were literally no go
zones in that they
had people patrolling their own militias
people who were armed with weapons
patrolling around to make sure that this
huge part of downtown right outside of
one of the
courthouses that they were trying weeks
on end to burn down
um that the only people who were there
were their allies and supporters and
members
so they've attacked countless number of
press
um as many people know they beat me
severely in 2019
and gave me a brain hemorrhage so
like they don't even hide the
extremism and the violence it's not like
they
do it behind closed doors they do it in
the open and it gets captured on video
and still people actually think that
we're dealing
with noble and anti-fascists who are
just opposing racists
[Music]